it was just eight days ago where no one
had been hired when we talked about the
openings actually the first domino fell
five days ago with urban meyer going to
the jaguars now
four are officially filled although i
still haven't seen a statement from the
jets on robert saul although he's the
guy we're expecting
dan campbell to be the head coach of the
lions uh but there are two vacancies
that we continue to monitor the eagles
and the texans and let me reiterate my
position
if i had options i would opt to wait
until next year
because i don't want either of those
jobs right now for different reasons
but also similar reasons i don't think
the deck is stacked in your favor well
yeah in either of those cities we saw
brian
ball get out of that conversation
yesterday i don't know how seriously he
was being considered for either one but
he obviously made the choice you know a
lot of the times mike as you and i we've
discussed a lot over the years
you only sometimes get one shot at this
thing so
you get a you know you you go go
somewhere and if it's dysfunctional and
you realize whoa
there's a lot of issues here do i want
to deal with this get fired two years
from now and then never get a head
coaching job opportunity ever again in
my life
that's what you have to balance here and
i think day ball was probably looking at
it going whoa
like you said there's issues there i'm
in a pretty good spot with a superstar
quarterback and an awesome offense
and he's going to play the the chance of
something else better will come about
next year
the term dysfunction means deviation
from the norms of social behavior in
a way regarded as bad um
you can fairly say that both
organizations right now looking for
coaches
are dysfunctional the mere fact that
doug peterson got fired three years
after winning a super bowl
shows that there was clearly dysfunction
whether or not the dysfunction lingers
who knows in houston it's it's
dysfunction on parade
so ball made the right call reportedly
staying put in buffalo for another year
he'll be on the a list next year as long
as josh allen's around
right if that had a different
quarterback all of a sudden dave all
wouldn't be a very good coach
when you have josh howard sure you're a
pretty damn good coach it makes you feel
better about taking these chances too
you just go
okay i can take a chance here i think my
guy's gonna be towards the top of the
football again as quarterback's
concerned
and that gives him a little leeway to do
that your guy josh mcdaniels
is being identified as a prime candidate
and look
i'm going to be very leery of top
candidate prime candidate favorite
whatever because
espn told me that brian dayball was the
favorite
to get the chargers job and he never was
it was always brandon staley it was all
i mean boy the chargers have become
the chargers the chargers are the cone
of silence there's a benefit to being
the team nobody cares about
i guess but it was always brandon staley
for them
and is it now josh mcdaniels for
philadelphia chris after saying no and
no and no and passing on this option and
that opportunity and this chance
why in the hell frankly all due respect
does he want to go coach the eagles
well ok well his story's a little
different and i don't you know i think
he's probably
looking at it going wait i don't have
josh allen with me i don't know where my
offense will go next year
am i guaranteed that i'm going to be we
we saw the
the sizzle or the the talk around josh
mcdaniels was far less this year than
it's been in the previous three or four
years right mike
so i think within that he's in a
different situation than brian dabal
and he's a guy that's already had you
know a head coaching job
and yes it was a failure it didn't work
out right
uh there was a lot of issues there and
we can discuss that it wasn't all just
josh mcdaniels but
i think he's got to look at it and go
wait i don't know if i'm going to get
another chance i might have to take this
and honestly i think like in a lot of
ways for josh mcdaniels and the eagles i
think it would be the perfect fit
josh is a guy you want to build with and
build around
he is you know again i don't say he's a
gm
right but he's got a lot of experience
in that he did do a lot of that stuff
in denver and i think at the very least
he understands the team building aspect
and what to do to where he can
conversate with a howie roseman and go
listen we're going to try to build this
type of offense and i need these type of
players and
blah blah blah on the defense and go
through it that way to where
i do think josh mcdaniels is a great fit
for this this role right here i think
he's made to kind of rebuild a team
and be that way but you have to be
patient and let the new england way kind
of filter out and play the long play
here where it might take two or three
years before he turns the team around
job number one carson wentz has to be on
board right whatever they do they've
empowered him at this point
sounds like him over doug peterson which
at its core it feels like that's what
they did
they want to see the return on their
investment they
want to see that last year was an
aberration we've talked about this
before ben roethlisberger in his third
season
was not good peyton manning in his
fourth season was not
good it turned around what did it take
in indianapolis
jim mora the elder out tony dungey
in that's what turned peyton manning
around so
you know you're picking the franchise
quarterback over the structure that's
in place to to use him if that structure
for whatever reason
doesn't believe in him anymore you find
somebody who does
and josh mcdaniels need not even engage
in the conversation with the eagles
unless he believes in carson wentz i
also heard yesterday right because
look because mcdaniels ran the show in
denver yeah howie roseman has
a major seat at the table in philly how
do these two
right coexist my understanding is
roseman
is fine with it it's just a matter of
talking
the owner jeffrey lurie into it and i
there's still this lingering
what the hell happened in indianapolis
that is hovering over josh mcdaniels and
i'll say this to jeffrey laurie
if you're watching good morning jeffrey
if you are uh chances i'll bet the under
on that one but
anybody out there who's thinking about
hiring josh mcdaniels i'll just tell you
to do this
because you you surely have the
resources you've got the time you've got
the expertise at your disposal
find your way all the way to the bottom
of the rabbit hole on what happened in
indianapolis
and and then and then decide what you
want to do with josh mcdaniels
isn't that fair no it's fair it's not an
easy
story i don't want to get into the story
i know bits and pieces of it
um but but you know if you're if you're
a billionaire who's thinking about
hiring the guy
you you should be able to get to the
bottom of it it shouldn't be that
difficult
and uh and then you can make your
decision on whether or not he's somebody
you want to do business with period well
yeah
listen the colts thing it's not a good
look for josh certainly we know that
yeah we we've screwed it up scrutinized
it everybody has
again i don't think this is a thing
where josh
mcdaniels was intending to screw over
the colts or went into it thinking he
was going to do that
i think that in the long play just from
what i know and to sum it up i think
it's a guy that has a love affair for
the new england patriots
and thought maybe he could be the next
guy after bill belichick
and also with that has a big family and
maybe wasn't quite sure if he wanted to
make that move and do that type of thing
and
i think bill probably sold him on
opening the vault
and going hey i'm going to really let
you be my right hand man
and doing those type of things and
that's where i think it kind of went
wrong there but it's certainly not a
good look for him and it hasn't helped
his cause
that's for sure uh but but i do think
this could be a good opportunity and and
yes you know that point you bring with
howie roseman is
is a big one can they can they coexist
can they build something together and be
on the same page
every time i hear the reference to bill
opening the vault when mcdaniels
returned after spurning the colts
right i remember that there was a sports
illustrated article
before he got hired by the broncos
saying the same damn thing
so i don't know how much of it the vault
never gets open with these guys
right right bill's never open in the
vault
maybe not even for his sons frankly but
uh
i i think that that things have changed
in new england
and there you know people thought well
he well he's clearly the successor to
bill belichick
when he stayed three years ago well bill
belichick's showing no indication he's
going to walk away any time soon and
and and i think you know that that that
notion that bill belichick gets to coach
the patriots
into his 80s if he wants to that
and i don't know what the over under is
on when the fans turn
but three four years i think three and a
half years of
not getting to the playoffs and just
kind of being blah
that's you know they're gonna have to
find an answer at quarterback or
uh or or i don't care how many super
bowls
you've won the fans are going to demand
something better
if you can't go out there and find
somebody who's going to perform better
at the quarterback position and and the
challenge would be
exacerbated for the patriots if they'd
lose josh mcdaniels
to the eagles if he ends up getting the
job
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports